powerful bursts of rain and winds
pounding different parts of town today
now what you're looking at are micro
bursts and they come in fast and they
can cause some serious damage so we want
to thank
tyler levitt for capturing this video
for you for us
and thank you for joining us here at 11
o'clock i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis you see this video and think it's
from a hurricane but this was actually
in henderson this afternoon
the storms also knocking out power
creating a real headache for many in the
southeast valley
we have team coverage tonight ted is
tallying up all the rain that came down
today but we start with sasha loftis for
an update
on repairs from nb energy sasha
denise and brian and the energy crews
are hard at work out here in the
southeast valley there's still
a lot of damage left over you can see
this downed tree behind me
one of many in the area here near
boulder highway and russell
also this road closure as crews work on
those power lines work on repairing
those
along boulder highway we spoke with a
lot of people who live in this area who
experienced this storm
they say they've never experienced
anything like it and it was honestly
pretty frightening
a southern nevada storm turns terrifying
it was like being in a hurricane 60 mile
an hour winds
swept through the valley thursday
leaving a string of destruction
and an entire community shaken within
three to four minutes the rain hit power
went down
mike plosky heard the moment this power
pole
snapped in half just 30 feet from his
home
in the southeast valley all of a sudden
a loud burst of wind and
snapping noise outside next thing you
know
sound of wire is hitting the ground he's
lived in las vegas his entire life
and says he's never seen anything like
this
very very surprising out of nowhere
three microbursts hit the valley
thursday marking the first
weather event with this kind of strength
since july of 2018.
pretty much like a tornado coming
through and just like a tornado they
pack a serious and dangerous punch
with some of the strongest known to down
airplanes
all this debris was blowing out and the
car would go
sidewards though this is something mike
and many others
don't want to experience again he's
grateful
to see everyone here out of harm's way
thankfully everybody is safe around here
back out here live i did just check the
envy energy outage map it looks like as
of now
just over 1300 people are still without
power tonight
the red cross has set up a shelter in
this area for those
with those continued power outages if
they are not repaired
by the morning we have more info on that
that location on our website
8newsnow.com